okay so your question okay that's fun
this is just real ice-skating terrifies
me I think it's because when I was
little I went once I just hugged the
railing mm-hmm I turned right around and
then I started emotionally either you
know maybe oh oh yeah exactly
my mom wasn't there so he too had to
feel it okay and when I'm out here I'm
just shaking and all I want his mom
peeps oh I am so thrilled to be sitting
here with Olympic ice dancing competitor
people that's correct
the Shibu Thani is this is Alex and Maya
thank you so much for taking the time
guys wow thank you for having us
how old were you when you started I was
four when I started school boy that
seems like a strange choice to wrap a
child and snow hands and just slide it
out there the feeling of really nailing
something is that like a special mindset
for you guys definitely I mean you train
so hard you prepare and you put so much
effort on the ice off the ice that when
you really do something well yeah a lot
of satisfaction your body wants to put
its hands up it wants to do these
celebratory things that actually accused
your brain to release dopamine huh do
you want to do in their dopamine oh I
love it we do have a nickname that we've
sort of developed over the years our
friends and some of the fans call us the
ship's it's ship sip it's a little bit
like I mean kind of sounds like a
diagnosis I was thinking you guys could
be the Shibu teeny X is it weird lifting
your sister or you kind of like yay but
gross ah ah actually like we've been
doing it so for so many years that you
know the gross factor really doesn't
bother me like what when you start it
you're like coach this gross fact please
come on I've got to do something else if
you guys want to just glide around like
angels now be happy to watch I'll sing
for you okay what are you gonna say I
have to sing something that's not real
cuz we can't afford it
i incised on it's not to be on the ice
time to be Shibu Taney acts on the eyes
yeah okay that's beautiful that's
impossible
pick up your sister like a guitar make
like it's not a big deal
thank you so much and sometime brother
and sister and the shoe boot a knee axe
back to you Pete future Pete that's to
you future geek future King future Peter